because wouldn't what you were
approached into you weren't so sure you
were known as the Austrian oak at that
stage yeah you were G wanted to act with
the Austrian oh what number one yeah
number one yeah not not at all
naughty New York actress no you move
from New York you're training with you
know Lee Strasberg and you know you
can't go to LA it'll ruin you you can't
do LA movies they suck I mean New York
New York is tough
so here's Arnold starring this film and
my people were very excited and I was
like I don't know I don't know I'm gonna
see for myself but I actually went to
set to see him whatever told me that
story I know who you were hesitating
working with but history is a great
thing history is a lovely thing but it
also it's quite a complicated thing
because you were married James Cameron
so when the three of you go back
together again was it the same as then
or was it more difficult was it less
difficult I mean I don't know how it can
be more difficult than the first it was
already very difficult then yeah but the
first movie little forget was a small
movie was a small budget movie it was
kind of an independent movie at six and
a half million dollars we had to go out
and do certain shots in Hollywood
without the permit permit I remember one
time I got out of the car and he says go
across this there's the street here and
sunset and go over to this car and punch
the window and in the front and heat
that shot and we didn't even own that
car so I walked across the street you
know kind of looked ramen a burlesque
like ended Bom Bom Bom and then they
looked around
punched through the window you know and
reached inside and we shot the first
movie was like six and a half million
dollars and so the second one was then
over a hundred million dollars it really
kind of elevated
[Music]
you